صباح النور صباح النور يعني بشوف هالضيعه
الحلوه ما بعيد يستغرب قرار جيسيكا جيسيكا
انت اليوم تركت الوظيفه تركتي عالم
المحاسبه وارجعت الى الجذور رجعت الى
الزراعه اليوم بعد ثلاث سنين من تاسيس
مشروعك على شو انت ندمانه ابدا مش ندمانه
بالعكس هذا احلى خيار اخذته بحياتي لانه
لقيت حالي ولقيت من مجال يعني انا بقدر
اكتب راسي بتمنى كل شخص انه ياخذ زيت
القرار ويلاقي حاله ويختار المجال الانسب
له اليوم صحيح رجعت الى الزراعه اللي هي
من اكثر المهن التقليديه والقديمه لكن
رجعت لقلبي
على شو عم تشتغلي وقديش توسع مشروعك من
ثلاث سنين لليوم مضبوط انا الصغير
مصنعين من اعاده تدوير البلاستيك فهذا
البروجيه بيخدمته وبقدر كمان ازرع بطريقه
طبيعيه بالتربه كمان نكس نوت تراب
والكومبوس
بهاي الطريقه اكون نحنا عم نتسهل عمليه
الزراعه وعم يشجع اكثر الشباب انها ترجع
وتزرع بطريقه كتير سهله لانه الزراعه
تطورت وهذا البروجي هو اكبر نيسان لهذا
الموضوع اليوم شو اكثر الزراعات اللي
بتنزرع على هذا الشكل لان انا عم بشوف
خطير اكثر خبريني شو الاشياء اللي نجحت
معك اللي ما نجحت معك
هذا المجال هو بعيد عن اختصاصه فانا اكيد
مرقت بمراحل تاجيرو ولكن هذا البروج هل
نوع من التقنيه هي لازم زراعه القصص الليف
الوراقيات
خاصه
[موسيقى]
يعني اليوم
لمين بيتوزع او يعني وين بيتصرف المنفوش
طبعا اكيد انا عندي زبونات يللي بيحبوا
هيك نمط من الزراعه الطبيعيه لنضيفه يا
اللي بتشبه طعم الضيعتنا القديمه الطبيعيه
كثير ما بنستعمل ابدا نوع من الكيميائيه
همم زراعه بنقلها
اورجانيك اااه
واكيد كل الاشخاص اللي بفضله هيك نمط من
الزراعه
بروجي الزراعه هو له اليوم شو التحديات
اللي واجهتك او ربما حتى الانتقادات يعني
اليوم همم انه مره تختار تشتغل بالزراعه
يعني هذا شيء ما كان مفروض عليك انت كان
عندك شغل ثاني بس مره تختار تروح على
الزراعه كونه مرقه حتى همم من طلقه نفسها
قديش هذا الشيء عرضك لا انت اديت ربما
اولى تحديات اكيد تحديات كتير كتير
بالمجتمعنا هذا البروجيه هو في عنده لمسه
انثويهاز اكيد التحديات كثير همم
بالفكره انه من انسانه مجله بقلب محدوديه
مكتب لا انسانه بقلب حقله وطبيعه فكان هذا
النقل النوعيه شوي غريبه خصوصي عم مجتمعنا
فمن خلال هذا البروجيه بوجهك كثير رساله
انثويه تنرجع انه المراه ما تتحدد بقلب
مجالات معينه كل المجلات لانها وتعطي من
لمستها ومن روحها وتخلي المشروع هو او
المجال هو يشبهها مش العكس يعني هون وجدت
جاسيكا نفسها همم وبالفعل يعني بالضبط هي
شو عم تحكي طبرينا يعني هل جيسيكا اخدت
الاعتبار القدره الشرائيه للمستهلك
اللبناني يعني اسعار
بالعاده تكون اغلى من غيرها
[موسيقى]
نادين الاستوديو عم تسال هل اخذت بعين
الاعتبار القدره الشرائيه للمواطن
اللبناني بما انه الاشياء نحنا بنعرف انه
هي عاده بتكون اغلى من غيره الحياه حبيت
انه وصل رساله من خلال هالبروجيه لا
مضروره يكون كثير اغلى فينا نحنا كلنا
نرجع نزرع زراعه طبيعيه مثل بالضبط مكان
جدودنا يزرعوا هل اكيد لانه بتاخد وقت
اكثر غير الكيمائيات يا اللي بتخليها انه
تسرع اكثر
الظروف كل العالم
[موسيقى]
عوده الى الكم الاستوديو واحنا بنشكركم
كثير علينا دويهي وعباد جاسيكا من جبال
باترون شمال لبنان شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]